[Music]
so time then for the press preview it's
our first look at what is on the front
pages of tomorrow's papers and tonight
we'll be checking out the headlines with
the journalists and author rachel shabby
and leader writer at the daily telegraph
tim stanley great to see you both we'll
chat in a moment after we've had a look
at some of those front pages beginning
with the observer which leads with the
leadership struggle across the
conservative party with the headline
bitter johnson trying to wreck sunak's
bid to replace him
the sunday express reports on the new
battle to save brexit as jacob rees-mogg
worries over who may be the next prime
minister
the sunday telegraph says tax cuts are
at the heart of sajid javid and jeremy
hunt's campaign bids for downey street
conservatives have warned the party is
ripping itself apart and have called for
an end to the toxic briefing against
rishi sunak that's the headline in the
sunday times
the sunday mirror says the labour leader
kia stammer has accused boris johnson of
squatting in downing streets while
members of his party jostle to replace
him
and just to remind you you can scan the
qr code that you see on screen join the
program and you can have a look at the
front pages of tomorrow's papers while
you're watching us discussing them and
to discuss them i'm joined once again by
rachel shabby and tim stanley very good
to see you both this evening um and so
much to talk about a lot to pick our way
through um breaking news this evening
sajid javid and jeremy hunt both
declaring their hand and tim they've
both done individual interviews for the
sunday telegraph and both interviews
make very interesting reading um but
they're both singing from the same hymn
sheet when it comes to taxation
bear off and if you would like a plug if
you if you don't mind a little plug here
i think the telegraph is going to be in
the newspaper in which the leader can
the leadership candidates are going to
lay out their views in the coming weeks
so we're going to be an absolute must
read the background to javid and hans
leadership campaigns of course is rishi
sunak
who yesterday said that he didn't want
to plow ahead with grand tax cuts
because he didn't think the economy was
ready for it which is a bold and brave
pitch it's a little identity entering a
beauty pageant wearing a balaclava well
hunt and javit has an opportunity there
because i suspect this contest is going
to be a very much
a content with the tax and economic
policy they both spied an opportunity to
announce their candidacies and put at
the center of them very very bold and
radical tax cuts
in the case of sanjit javed there are so
many of them had to write them down he's
going to wrap the national insurance tax
rise is going to ditch the planned
corporation tax increase it's going to
bring forward the income tax cut to next
year and there'll be a temporary fuel
duty cut as well and what jeremy hunt
wants to do the two headline tax cuts
he's running with are first of all a
five-year holiday on business rates and
secondly he wants to cut corporation tax
down to 15 percent there are actually a
number of candidates that are suggesting
that matter one including sajid javid so
that looks like it's going to be where a
lot of candidates are going to end up
settling if they did that it would mean
that britain would have the less the
joint lowest corporation tax within the
g20 so it would be quite a quite a game
changer on tax other candidates have
announced as well today grant shaps
nadim zahawi we have comment pieces and
words from them as well they've chosen
to place an emphasis upon defense
spending we'll see ukraine's at the top
of their minds
but i i predicted for some time now but
i think the big issue in this election
will be tax because the national
insurance tax increase under rishi sunac
was so controversial and it doesn't
surprise me
have gone straight forward yeah well on
that point uh rachel it's interesting
isn't it that sanji javid has said he
wants to reverse the rise in national
insurance to fund uh nhs backlogs uh
funds social care reform as well he's
saying that in the sunday telegraph and
yet um he didn't seem to complain about
it when he was health secretary
well
yeah but i think that speaks to um
a lot of things that
uh
conservative cabinet members didn't
speak out about while they were in boris
johnson's cabinet and then suddenly
conveniently um were hand ringing with
you know a newfound moral compass over
the last few days um so i think that
speaks to that but let's just put this
into context britain's corporation tax
is currently 19 it is the lowest of
european oecd countries uh germany has
29
france has 28 spain has 25
those are all figures from the tax
foundation
the reason that
these
contenders want to reload to such
alarmingly
dangerously low levels
is because
boris johnson's conservatives are now
fashioned in his name they are a hard
right ideological party they believe in
achingly low taxes uh they are
essentially a money delivery mechanism
for the rich
the conservatives have been in power for
12 years in those 12 years
britain is you know has had wage
stagnation um we've got increasing
number of people living using food banks
we've got increasing number of people
plunged into poverty including children
including homes where there's at least
one parent working
those two things conservatives empower
and britain in eye-watering levels of
poverty and hardship are related they're
not disconnected facts and now we can
see that these conservative contenders
for leadership
want to
want to really cement
all of this
economic hardship that they've inflicted
on on the population that's what the
contenders are promoting because that's
what the party is that's what the
membership is that's what the mps are
that's what the tory donors are and they
are the ones who just
our future yeah i want him to come back
on that because i i know you've got
something to say but i also want us to
move on to the front of the observer as
well so a quick word on on on that tim
and then i'll ask you about the observer
sure first of all uh in his interview
with us sanjay javad answers your point
jonathan about why when he was health
secretary he was happy to see the tax
increases his explanation is i was in
charge of health so i wanted money for
health i wasn't chancellor it wasn't his
job and that's a fair enough answer
ministers are not going to turn down
money that's put into their departments
uh on the tax point uh
kemi badknock has also written a piece
for us in which she explains the
thinking behind tax cuts which is that
it's a supply-side argument the lower
you you put taxes the higher the revenue
because it generates growth which could
be shared uh for the people and that can
help raise their salaries et cetera
and we have a poll
which finds that 56 percent of britain's
do favor tax cuts um and that's actually
a higher percentage than tory voters 52
percent of tory voters want tax cuts but
actually 56 percent of all
time
so they're actually very popular it's
not just about the rich it's about
everyone okay i'm sorry i'm sorry to
keep i'm going to keep the pace up just
because we are really short of time and
i want to we we're we're meant to be
looking at the front pages so i'm just
going to talk to you about the observer
very quickly tim um this is pitching um
uh rishi sunak sort of as a bit of an
outlier isn't it because he is all about
belt tightening and the front of the
observer uh says not only is he uh uh an
outlier in that sense but also uh there
was a lot of briefing from number 10
against him really um because he began
the whole ball rolling with boris
johnson's resignation
yes the observer suggests that uh boris
johnson is very very sore about the way
that he went he's sore about which is
soon as resignation and they're going to
try and make life as difficult as
possible not just for him but for anyone
who replaces him the observer points out
that boris johnson has filled the
cabinet with appointments some of them
people say are even unnecessary jobs
that didn't previously exist like deputy
leader of the commons um and that they
are he is doing it because he's making
life difficult for the person who takes
over who will then have to sack many of
these people and replace them i'm sure
number 10 would reply to that by saying
hey we've probably got a two month at
least campaign ahead of us we've got to
have a functioning government therefore
it would be irresponsible to leave those
positions vacant but either way there's
there's no escaping that this campaign's
going to be bitter there are already
charges flying around about tax and
various other things it's going to be a
pretty ugly contest yeah and it's a
similar theme rachel on the front of the
sunday times their headline quite simply
tourists tear themselves a part of
attacks
um yeah there's um there's bad blood
isn't there um and there's going to be a
lot of blood letting and it's being done
on our time and our expense the times is
reporting pretty eye-watering details
including that um you know dossiers of
incriminating evidence is being sent to
labor
um by various leadership candidates to
be used against uh potential rivals
in that race so that's the depth to
which they have sung but of course that
is all more
um that is more proof of how you know
they just need to get on with this but
also if boris johnson is being such a
disruptive factor and force
uh why is he still prime minister why
why is he still got the power to do any
of this it's absurd
okay and let's just finish uh very
quickly on the sunday express new battle
to save uh brexit tim
jacob rees-mogg uh warns that uh the
people who have felt most validated in
the last few days by events have been
extreme remainers
and he's worried that whoever takes over
will attempt to chip away at brexit um i
don't know if i agree with jacob on this
one i think that brexit is now a
consensus within the conservative party
and once the area of tax has been
discussed and moved on from i think
they're going to move pretty sharpish
onto northern ireland as well before the
leadership contest even began for
example jeremy hunt took a very hawkish
line on northern ireland i i understand
his concerns and uh he's right to flag
them but
you know even kier starman now supports
brexit yeah quick thought on this rachel
before we go to the break
i mean there's always a betrayal
narrative with brexiteers isn't there
that's just part of the dna but also i
suspect he's just trying to flush out um
the former remainer candidates who all
of course had to pledge loyalty to
brexit in order to still be
a party
okay all right we'll leave it there uh
for the moment plenty more still to come
including the sunday mirror with kia
bring on the general election that's
their headline discussing that uh and
some of the other stories on the front
pages when we come back
[Music]
uh welcome back part two of the press
preview rachel and tim uh still with us
uh now before the break uh rachel was
asking the question why is boris johnson
still prime minister uh tim the front of
the mirror asking the same question kia
bring on the general election accusing
boris johnson of squatting in downing
street
i think the tories would be mad to hold
an election right now
it ain't going to happen but i can
understand why sakira is rearing to go
it's going to be a very interesting
change of the political scene of course
when the new leader is selected uh kia
has kirsten has benefited from a
contract between his style he's very
he places a great device upon trust and
integrity and of course he's just been
cleared by the dharma police or compared
with boris johnson well
when boris is gone and when star is up
against someone else it's going to be a
completely different dynamic
and the tories are hoping cool momentum
will go back to them rachel in the polls
since boris johnson resigned the party
uh has lost on average three points um i
believe labour up to 11 points ahead now
do you think um the conservatives
actually can turn it around
well i have no idea but what i do know
is that you know when k k star is on the
front page of the mirror he's written
for the mirror and he says changing the
person at the top isn't going to clean
out the rotten culture from throughout
the party only by booting out a lot of
them will britain get the fresh start it
needs it's hard to argue with that i
mean it's not just boris johnson is it
this has been going on for years we've
had several
um
tory uh leaders foisted upon us albeit
the boris johnson himself in an election
but it is mad it just is objectively mad
that our prime minister should be
decided by what two 200 000
um conservative members with really
fundamentalist and bigoted views oh and
overwhelming the majority of them
believe that islam is a threat to the
way of life of the uk
over 50 of them are thought trump was a
great president
it's
it's just not that the next pm should be
decided by this lot i mean objectively
tim fundamental fundamentalist and
bigoted views
i think the word objectively is carrying
a great deal there i don't know where
those uh where those polls or those
figures come from but constitutionally
would be no different to if a labor
prime minister changed and was replaced
by the labour party and of course the
labour party and its wisdom chose jeremy
corbyn as its leader uh leaders have not
been foster spoiled onto the british
public david cameron was elected theresa
may was elected boris johnson was
elected in a massive landslide i i think
labour's gonna be very careful about
being sanctimonious about any of this uh
when did the expenses scandal have under
labor when did the iraq war happen under
labour all politicians are tamed
all political parties are tainted by
scam
i really do i think it's unwise to try
and take the model hike okay and i just
want to finish on one other store away
from the politics we'll talk more about
all of this in half an hour rachel don't
worry i just want to talk about the
petrol crisis uh because the times has
quite an interesting story just about
how difficult it is for
people you asking me yeah sorry rachel
yeah yeah absolutely so um this is uh
there is a
there's a report from worcester the
reporter is um in worcester where um
uh an employer is reporting that
increasingly people are now just having
to walk walk to work because they cannot
afford
uh the spiralling cost of petrol we're
now a um you know 100 pound tank for the
average family obviously that is just
absurd and this is the trouble that all
the time that the tories are squabbling
over their future liver uh leader we're
in this eye-watering cost of living
crisis uh martin lewis the financial
journalist has been um doing media
rounds over the last few days and the
absolute urgency of his voice when he's
warning about the horrendous economic
hardships that are about to before this
country come october for instance he's
talking about
energy bills rising to over three
thousand pounds he points out that the
uh state pension on on average is just
under ten thousand pounds it cannot be
right that a third of a pension is going
to go on just paying energy costs that's
completely unsustainable
um and so you know all of these things
just need urgent attention today
and instead we're having a tory psycho
drama again